polici poli une prise d'otage en direct
à la télévision des évasions
spectaculaires de chef de gang un
candidat à la présidentielle assassinée
c'est la première fois qu'on voit des
attaques coordonnées simultanées sur le
territoire national cette semaine dans
la grande histoire je vous raconte
comment l'équateur un pays d'Amérique
latine réputé tranquille a basculé en
peu de temps dans le narcotrafic et
l'ultraviolence jamais l'économie de la
drogue a été si
prospère
nous sommes le 9 janvier à guayakille la
deuxème ville d'Équateur située sur la
côte pacifique des hommes armés font
irruption en plein direct sur le plateau
d'une télévision public ces
narcotrafiquants prennent en otage des
journalistes et des employés de la
chaîne la scène est diffusée pendant de
longues minutes avant l'intervention des
forces de
l'ordre
toute l'opération était pour montrer
qu'il pouvait intervenir il s'agit
absolument d'une démonstration de force
en casoulé plusieurs assaillants font
des signes d'appartenance au gang ils
seront arrêtés par les forces de l'ordre
d'après les autorités personne n'a été
tué cette prise d'otage s'est déroulé
dans un moment de grande tension dans le
pays pour comprendre comment on en est
arrivé là je vous propose de revenir un
petit peu en
arrière dimanche 7 janvier adolpo Matias
alias phito désigné comme l'ennemi
public numéro 1 s'évade de la prison de
haute sécurité de Guayakil depuis 2020
phito est à la tête de los choneros le
cartel le plus important du pays qui
compterait environ 8000 hommes ce chef
et ce cartel sont en fait
fondamentalement des sous-traitants des
cartels mexicain plus puissant queeux en
particulier celui de Sinaloa à laquelle
la figure chapeau guusman est encore
largement associé phito le chef des
choneros s'était déjà échappé une
première fois en 2013 avant d'être
rattrapé 3 mois plus
tard de sa vie peu d'information filtre
si ce n'est son passé de chauffeur de
taxi on sait qu'il a un grand charisme
c'est vraiment un chef qui a réussi à
maintenir sa légitimité dans la prison
de Guayakil qu'il dirige en sousmain
phito organiser des soirées il y a même
tourné le clip d'une chanson
[Musique]
les différentes prisons sont devenu des
bases d'opération des gangs puisque
l'État a perdu le contrôle sur le
système pénitenciers donc les grands
chefs des mafias qui sont incarcérés la
plupart d'entre eux continuent à être
les chefs de leurs organisations à la
suite de l'évasion du chef de los
choneros le président nouvellement élu
Daniel Noboa l'éat d'urg jusqu'à sa
captureori le lendemain de l'évasion de
phito c'est autour d'un autre chef de
gang de s'échapper de prison Fabrio
colon pic le chef de Los Lobos un cartel
rival
deeros ce sont ces hommes qui ser à
l'origine de la prise d'otage à la
télévision
publi n'était pas responsable qui n'ont
pas participé à ces attaques mais bon
est-ce qu'il faut les croire il y a trop
d'inconnus encore pour pouvoir vraiment
établir ce qui s'est
produit quelques jours avant la prise
d'otage des membres de l'oslobos avaient
publié une vidéo dans laquelle il menaça
directement
l'État depuis l'évasion de phito
plusieurs mutineries et prise d'otage
ont touché les prisons à travers tout le
pays des ravisseurs ont publié sur les
réseaux sociaux des vidéos montrant des
gardiens pris en otage et menacés
d'exécution pour comprendre cette
escalade fulgurante de la violence il
faut revenir encore quelques années en
arrière au milieu des années 2010 le
taux de criminalité en Équateur était
encore l'un des plus faibles de toute
l'Amérique latine l'équateur était
vraiment le pays qui avait été le plus
épargné dans la donandine je dirais même
presque en Amérique latine du fléo des
narcos du trafic de drogue du crime
organisé les Équatoriens le disaent
beaucoup l'île de paix de la région on
assiste à ce qu'on appelle la
mexicanisation de l'Amérique latine
c'est-à-dire finalement le fait que les
les grands cartels mexicains aujourd'hui
opère non plus seulement au Mexique non
plus seulement en Amérique centrale mais
dans toute l'Amérique latine et ça c'est
quelque chose qui a commencé dans les
années 2010 et qui s'est accéléré il y a
eu des changements dans la logique du
trafic international de drogue et
l'Équateur est devenu plus important
dans le transit de la drogue dans le
transport de la drogue dans la
logistique de la drogue l'équateur est
tout simplement situé entre deux
principaux producteurs de cocaïne au
monde que sont la Colombie et le Pérou
et c'est devenu un hub de mise en
circulation et de diffusion
d'acheminement de la cocaïne pour
nourrir deux routes la première vers
l'Europe et puis de l'autre côté par la
zone Pacifique à partir de la ville de
goayquille qui part vers les
États-Unis des raisons pour laquelle la
drogue passe aujourd'hui par l'équateur
c'est parce qu'il y a eu un écroulement
un effondrement des institutions et de
l'état donc une sorte de vide que les
organisations criminelles ont pu
utiliser après 10 ans de gouvernement de
gauche les libéraux arrivent au pouvoir
et mettent en place une politique
d'austérité de nombreux postes
budgétaires sont coupés le gouvernement
ferme le ministère de l'intérieur c'est
trop cher le gouvernement ferme clôture
vraiment le ministère de la Justice le
prix de l'essence est multiplié par de
et les prix des denrées alimentaires
s'envolent l'équateur connaît alors le
plus important mouvement social de son
[Musique]
histoire le gouvernement instore l'état
d'urgence il y a une nouvelle
augmentation de la pauvreté en Équateur
et on sait que évidemment la pauvreté
égalité le chômage tout ça c'est un
terrain fertile pour pour que le crime
organisé puisse réimplanter l'équateur
propose si je puis dire au
narcotrafiquant un avantage
supplémentaire c'est que c'est une
économie qui est dollarisée l'équateur
vit avec une monnaie qui n'est pas une
monnaie nationale c'est le dollar et
bien évidemment pour les
narcotrafiquants c'est très important
pour pouvoir blanchir les profits
réalisés par l'économie criminelle
depuis 2018 les assassinats dans les les
rues ont augmenté de 800 % en 2022
l'équateur a connu l'année la plus
meurtrière de son histoire il est
désormais l'un des pays les plus
violents d'Amérique latine on a
aujourd'hui en Équateur ceon app un
narcoétat où la corruption s'est
généralisée et c'est pour ça que on peut
finalement comparer l'équateur des
années 2020 à ce que fut la Colombie
cette Colombie des anné
0 accusé de corruption le guillass est
menacé par une procédure de destitution
il décide de dissoudre l'Assemblée et
convoque de nouvelles élections
présidenocrtica
constu
puor narcotra invité Dansette campagne
pour montr était l'un des acteurs
politiques l'un des candidats Fernando
vill viicencio dénonce des menaces de
mort de la part de phito quelques jours
plus tard il est assassiné de trois
balles dans la tête en sortant d'un
meeting toutes les personnes arrêtées
pour ce meurtre ont été assassiné en
prison en l'espace de 24 heures 6 la
même nuit dans une prison et la 7e
personne dans une autre prison le
lendemain donc euh évidemment ces
personnes ont été assassinées pour
qu'ell ne puisse pas être porter
témoignage pour qu'elle ne puisse pas
dire révéler à à la justice qui a
ordonné le le meurtre le 15 octobre 2023
c'est Daniel Noboa Fils de l'homme le
plus riche d'Équateur qui remporte
l'élection présidentielle c'est la
grande bourgeoisie équatorienne liée
effectivement à l'industrie suite à la
prise d'otage en direct à la télévision
le Président déclare le pays en état de
conflit armé interne l'équateur rentre
aujourd'hui officiellement dans dans la
politique impulsée à Washington et
relayée à Mexico de ce qu'on appelle
justement la guerre contre les droguesou
militarisation de la lutte contre les
drogues bien sûr la militarisation a des
résultats il y aura des cartels
démantelés des chefs arrêtés d'autres
tués mais bien sûr la stratégie de fond
de cette approche de considérer queon va
résoudre le problème en détruisant
l'offre finalement mais le petit
problème c'est que c'est la demande qui
ne cesse d'augmenter dans des pays qui
ne sont ni l'équateur ni d'autres hein
c'est les états Unis c'est l'Europe
c'est l'Asie et cetera et tant que cette
cela existe il y aura toujours des
cartels et des et des gangs pour et bien
tenter leur chance pour continuer à
faire VI ce
trafic merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que vous y voyez un
peu plus clair sur la situation en
Équateur n'hésitez pas à mettre un like
c'est super important pour nous vous
pouvez aussi me poser des questions en
commentaire et me proposer des idées de
sujet pour les prochaines semaines en
tout cas si cette vidéo vous a intéressé
je vous mets les liens des ép épisode
consacré à Emma Coronel la femme d'chapo
Guzman et au PCC la confraerie
criminelle la plus puissante du Brésil
vous pouvez retrouver les liens aussi
dans la description un dernier mot pour
remercier toutes les équipes de brutes
qui m'ont aidé à réaliser cette vidéo et
sur ce je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine pour une autre grande
[Musique]
histoire